what is your favorite cheese
ooh
i think i was asked that yesterday
yesterday i was asked my top three
favorite cheeses
and i said uh brie
burrata
and provolone
but i also like the type of cheese where
you misspell chess
and you just say cheese
what's my favorite what is this okay
this from position wins
what is this where'd it go
[Music]
i don't even know what this is
it looks so circular
it's like a circular square
where's my king
what color am i
what is life
who am i playing even
i think i saw their username briefly i'm
going to turn off zen mode
i'm playing scary chicken
[Music]
i'm so scared right now
what's my favorite cheese opening
it's probably when i like opened the
package of the the four cheese blend
wait what so white's moving this way
which means i'm moving this way
and my king is here
and i'm black
okay i have four bishops
wow
i also have how many queens i have four
queens
so it's equal material
okay
i think i can roll with this is my queen
trapped
i think my queen is kind of trapped
oh no my queen
but white doesn't promote when they take
it
or do they they do
this was my eighth rink
light can promote
oh no
i'm so confused i wonder how scary
chicken thought of this
my queen hanging
but white's queen is also hanging
i don't care about this bishop i just
want to make a queen
i'm gonna make a new queen too right
or a new knight probably a new queen
what about a hot tub cheese stream
earlier i was taking notes of stream
ideas
stream ideas
i'll add that to a list hot tub cheese
stream
okay
uh let's take with this queen
so my pawn defends the bishop
this is so mind-bending
if i take takes takes everything can
take back
also white has a triple battery
hmm
i might as well take him once
so i'm realizing like this this is the
next pawn that's closest to promoting
thank you rookie
rookie a
i'm still a little bit bewildered
but i have four queens and white only
has two so
i think that's a good sign
okay now i only have three queens
about to lose another one
take that
so the rook the knight or the bishop can
take
but now i have this move
surprise surprise
wait how my queen get to that square
initially oh the queen started there
was my queen trapped
wow
i think my queen is trapped
i didn't see that move
i thought i was being so clever but now
like queen has no squares
what is this witchcraft
do i have any checks this file is half
open
but more half open for
wait no this is not even a file it's a
rank
it looks like a file
this is a file this file is technically
open because there's no pawns on it
i think i should just take the bishop
and then i'll take this pawn with check
wait so close to promoting two things
though
but white's in check and both of white's
dark or no
both the white's bishops are hanging
dark square and light swear
i'm so excited to see what stockfish
will say about this
[Music]
game f4
oh pawns can move two squares from the
starting square
wow
here's to chess and cheese mimrosen
thank you thomas tansdana
yeah i don't currently have any cheese
in my fridge right now
but maybe i'll pick some up kind of
hungry for cheese now
okay so
i mean licha says i'm up
two minor pieces
which
i'll probably believe it's true but
white's very close to making two queens
i can't really stop this move
now i might as well take a no the
bishop's not hanging though
i forgot the knight defends it
it's the same case on this side
i have this move
because this pawn is uh this pawn is
pinned to the king
from oh
there's two second increments
and now we're gonna have to start
playing
quicker i've been so flustered by the
position i forgot about the time
my opponent's so courteous
but i i really don't need more time i
can live on the
increments uh
yeah let's keep the pin
i'm still threatening the pawn i have
two attackers
there's only one defender okay now
there's two defenders
um
what's my plan
this move
hi youtube and mommy play me senpai
um
i'll i'll consider it thank you paxelli
but i really need to devote my full
mental attention to
whatever is happening right in front of
me now
white's about to make another queen
but my king feels relatively safe
like a little bit safer than white's
king
um
yeah let's start pushing
[Music]
but how to do
this i don't even know my plan here
maybe this move
the problem is if i play this i get oh i
don't get mated though
okay
it's gonna turn into a time scramble
i just realized i have quadruple pawns
offering a trade
don't hurt me
unless rook's not defended
i can't uh i can't easily promote
um
okay now i can promote soon
oh i didn't see that
don't hurt me
that was a really bad move
yeah i have to run this way
white has two queens and i have none
i'm about to make another one
there is surely nothing other than the
single purpose of the present moment a
man's whole life is a succession of
moment after moment there will be
nothing
and nothing else to pursue
who
also what does this mean
why played really well that game
oh scary chick i just realized scary
chicken is higher rated than me
what a game
i got cheese mated
whatever that means
okay let's let's see the computer
analysis
look at this graph oh i was better in
the opening
white fell for my opening preparation
[Music]
wow it's equal
wait is it equal
oh white's
wow
well it's apparently winning or losing
depending what move is played this is
the best move though
but
it seems like sawfish is just confused
bishop takes b2 best move i took takes
wow we played the top engine line
bishop takes a1
so after this
that's crazy so the knight was poisonous
i just assumed white didn't see the
night was hanging but my queen just got
trapped
and then the rest of the game i was
losing except here
why is bishop c3
oh i should have yeah i should have
tried to promote quickly
and then there was a moment here so
let's see what happened
i'm losing losing losing
and then apparently this move was a
blunder
oh
simple tactics
it's hard to see simple tactics when the
position isn't so simple
[Music]
wow
okay um well if i put that on youtube
this will probably go on youtube i think
thanks for watching the future youtube
viewers
let me know if you want to see more
content like this
or let me know what type of content you
want to see in the future
i have a whole list of content ideas
i'm happy to add to the list so leave
your
your thoughts in the comments
and then i'll read them